[Music]
Christian.
Hey
[Music]
Oh my gosh.
Hello.
>> Hello.
>> Okay. Welcome. Welcome to the table. My
name is Janine Horton and my pronouns
are she and her. I want to welcome you
all to the table. I want you to know
that you're not only welcomed here, but
you are celebrated here. And I have a
couple of announcements on things that
we can all celebrate together.
A lot of them have already been
mentioned if you were in the table
meeting. So, uh, those of you who
weren't, here we go. On Sunday, October
the 5th, right here at 5:00 PM, we're
going to have our next Sunday Unbound
service. This will be different from the
past versions that we've done as it will
be a night of worship and prayer through
music, communion, and other expressions.
And also we won't be having a potluck.
We will be having our first Sunday Hat
Creek gathering.
Okay. We hope to see you there. North
Texas Pride booth on October the 11th.
We'll have a booth at the North Texas
Pride in Plano. Uh we will need
volunteers to be at the booth in shifts
from 12:00 p.m. to 5:00 p. p.m. to
represent our community. if you're
interested,
the infamous scan the QR code.
All right, we're also if you are
interested in becoming a member at the
table or you simply want to learn a
little bit more about us as a community
and how to get involved, then sign up
for our welcome to the table class.
It'll be happening one week from today,
which will be 29th
28th. Sorry about that.
Um, and oh, it says it right here on my
notes. September the 28th from 3 to
4:30. And again, scan the QR code for
more information.
You know, we know sometimes that it can
be a little bit nerve-wracking to come
in or perhaps you're just part of a
disability community and you get
anxious. And so, we wanted to let you
know that we have a bucket that is
filled with all kinds of noiseancelling
headphones, little fidgets, coloring
sheets, and you're welcome to go over
there and help yourself to anything
that's going to make you feel more
comfortable uh here in this community.
And so we just ask that you return them
to the bucket at the end of the service.
I wanted to bring your attention to the
candles that I lit at the beginning of
the service.
Uh these candles are a sign of the
presence of Christ within us,
fully divine and fully human.
And now we exit the kingdom of noise and
hurry and productivity.
We enter the kingdom of silence and
stillness and simplicity.
A sacred space,
a place for prayer, worship and
adoration,
a place to behold Christ, the revelation
of God,
the heartbeat of creation.
Just allow the unforced rhythms of grace
to remind you
to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Thank you, John. Mean, if you guys would
like to stand with us, we're going to
get started with worship. And um we're
actually gonna do a song that we haven't
done here before. It's called Never See
the End. And um it's kind of playing off
that passage in Joshua. And I just
wanted to quickly read in that first It
says, "I will give you every place where
you set your foot as I promised Moses.
Your territory will extend from the
desert to Lebanon and from the great
river the Euphrates, all the Hittite
country to the great sea on the west. No
one will be able to stand up against you
all the days of your life. As I was with
Moses, so I will be with you. I will
never leave you nor forsake you. be
strong and courageous.
And um that passage, you'll hear it the
themes of it coming through here. But um
even at our darkest, at our worst, when
things seem the most hopeless, I hold on
to those words that he will never leave
us. He will not forsake us. And as a
community, we have the opportunity to
speak those out. And that's powerful
when we can remind ourselves and each
other that we're holding on to that
truth as a community. He won't leave us.
He will not forsake us. He is with us.
So, we're going to go ahead and get
started tonight. We hope that you'll
join in and sing out as you are
comfortable.
[Music]
Where can we run?
Where can we hide?
But you will not find
us.
In the deepest of depths, in the highest
of heights,
your love chases
us.
No matter where we've been,
no matter what we've done,
we can't escape
your love.
[Music]
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end.
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
[Music]
Though we pass through
the flood,
you will be with
us.
Though we walk through the valley of the
darkest of night,
your love will be
a light.
When we are in plenty
or we are in ones,
you will always be
enough.
[Music]
>> We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your good. Let's sing that again. We
will never We will never see the end. We
will never see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. And we will
never see the end
of your garden.
[Music]
And in our darkest hour
and our hardest days,
we will not have to be afraid.
For you will never leave.
You will not forsake
the promises you have made. Let's sing
that again. And in our darkest hours, on
our hardest days,
we will not have to be afraid.
For you will never leave.
You will not forsake
the promises you have made.
In our darkest hours, in our hardest
days,
we do not have to be afraid.
For you will never leave.
You will not forsake
the promises you have made.
And we can say
we will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
[Music]
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your birth.
[Music]
All right, kiddos. You guys are
dismissed to go to your classes.
Looks like you teachers are going to
have a lot of fun energy going on in
there tonight. So, good luck, teachers.
We love you. Thanks for loving on our
kids so well.
And as they leave with their teachers,
we are going to transition into what we
call prayers of the people. And it's
actually a tradition that's been passed
down through Christian history. So we
invite you guys to follow along. On the
screens, the parts in red, we will read
all together out loud. And then there
will be a portion in the middle where we
leave some space for you to just offer
up anything that you're carrying into
this room tonight. whether it's a person
or a situation that's heavy on your
heart, we just invite you to share that
aloud. And um we want to hold that
before God together as a community.
Jesus, for this city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth that you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and the suffering. We pray to
you for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our heart. We pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep
sense of your presence.
Amen.
[Music]
My life is yours.
My hope is in you only.
I have you.
[Music]
You made Make this
holy
and holy.
[Music]
>> Your glory is so beautiful.
I fall to my knees.
>> The heartbeat of my life is to worship
in your life. Your glory is so
beautiful.
>> Your glory is so beautiful.
[Music]
My life is yours.
>> My life is yours.
>> My hope is in you only.
>> My hope you
>> my heart you
made this s
holy and holy.
[Music]
Your glory is so beautiful.
>> I fall to my knees and
the heartbeat of my life is to worship
in your life. Your glory is so
beautiful.
[Music]
>> Your glory is so beautiful.
Oh
yeah.
[Music]
Let's sing your glory.
Glory.
Hallelu
Jesus. You are good.
Glory.
Hallelu.
Jesus.
You are good.
>> Glory, glory,
hallelujah.
Jesus, you are good.
Glory, glory,
hallelu.
Jesus, you are good.
can wash away my sins.
Nothing but the blood of Jesus.
[Music]
What can make me whole again?
Nothing but the blood of Jesus.
Oh, precious
is the P
that makes me white as snow.
No
other fells I know. Nothing but the
blood of Jesus.
Oh,
nothing but the blood of Jesus.
[Music]
Oh,
glory, glory,
hallelujah.
Jesus, you are good. and sing it out.
Glory, glory,
hallelujah,
Jesus, you are good.
>> One more time. Let's sing that.
>> Glory, glory,
hallelu
Jesus,
you are good.
[Music]
How can I respond
to the love that you have lavished on?
to the love that you have lavished on
me?
I don't have much.
I don't have much. But I have a heart
that beats for you. I have a heart that
bits for you.
[Music]
Every part of me,
wants to love you like you love me,
Lord.
Every part of me
wants to love you like you love me.
My Lord,
I don't have much.
I don't have much. But I have a heart
that beats for you. I have a heart that
beats for you. I don't have much.
I don't have much. But I have a heart
that beats for you. I have a heart that
beats for you. I have a heart that beats
for you. I have a heart that beats for
you. I have a heart that beats for you.
I have a heart that beats for you. I
have a life I'll give to you. I have a
life I'll give to you. I have a life
I'll give to you. I have a life I'll
give to you. I have a heart that beats
for you. I have a heart that beats for
you. I have a heart that beats for you.
I have a heart that beats for you. I
have a life I'll give to you. I have a
life I'll give to you. I have a life
I'll give to you. I have a life I'll
give to you. I don't have much.
I don't have much, but I have a heart
that beats for you. I have a heart that
beats for you. I don't have much.
I don't have much. But I have a heart
that beats for you. I have a heart that
beats for you.
[Music]
God,
some days it feels like we have very
little to give, very little to offer.
But even there, your grace meets us and
your grace is enough.
Your goodness follows us all the days of
our life.
And you will never forsake us.
You don't leave us behind.
You don't walk away,
but you are a God who is with us. You
are a God who is faithful.
God, we anchor into that tonight.
We're so grateful for your presence
that's always there, that's always
leading and guiding us, calling us
forward.
deeper into your love,
calling us back home to who you created
us to be, your children,
your creation,
your good work.
God, will we find ourselves more and
more at home there?
We invite you in.
Speak to us.
We give you our heart. We give you our
life
in Jesus name. Amen.
Would you guys turn to the people on
either side of you and say, "The peace
of Christ be with you.
Well, grace and peace.
So glad to be with you all. So so glad.
My name is Brett. Pronouns he him. And
uh yeah, it's a joy joy to be with you
in this space. And as always, that
includes those joining us online. Glad
you all could be with us. And don't
forget to get your communion elements
for later in the service. And uh also
anyone here tonight who is new, thanks
for being here. I know it can take a lot
of courage to come through those doors
and uh interact, you know, with a new
group of people and and depending on
church backgrounds and history and uh
that can be a lot of times there can be
a lot of pain associated with church uh
which is a super sad thing but it is
totally reality. You know, it's like
very real. So, um, we're really really
glad that you're you're here among us.
So, uh, we are in week two in our series
titled The Good Book, Fresh Insights
into an Ancient Text. And, uh, we do I'm
doing standalone messages, though. So,
even if you weren't here for last week,
you'll be able to, uh, follow along. All
right. And basically what we're kind of
doing is we're just wrestling with
scripture with what it is, how to read
it, how to interpret it well. And the
reason this is particularly relevant for
a community like ours is because like on
the one hand like we love the
scriptures. We're so grateful it's this
is how you know uh we learn about Christ
from the gospels for example. You know
it's like essential to Christian faith
and practice. On the other hand, the
Bible has been deployed in really
hurtful ways. And so it it kind of has
to be it's a it's a more complicated
book than certain wings of the church
would like to admit. And so that has to
be kind of worked through theologically.
And uh so that's kind of some of what
we're doing, you know, in the series is
I'm trying to give a little bit of an
approach and a framework to maybe how to
think about it. And uh and then I'll
leave it of course to you to to kind of
see where you agree, where you might
disagree. Even like our meetups are
going to be, you know, many of them uh
base their discussions on the the
message. So, you know, you all have a
chance to kind of hash it through and
and start working out some of your own
thoughts and, you know, theology on
scripture and how you want to approach
it. Uh and that's that's great. So, if
you would like a resource though, one um
book I'm drawing very heavily from for
this series is the Eastern Orthodox
theologian uh named John Bear. in his
book in accordance with the scriptures
the shape of Christian theology uh in
particular the message last week and
this week are very heavily influenced by
the opening chapters of his book next
week will be a little more Richard Roar
it'll be like a little different
direction but uh I just yeah if you want
something like you want a little deeper
dive then bear is the great place to go
he is writing he's an academic so it is
um a little bit academic so fair warning
on that but it's it's very very good so
the title of my message uh specific to
tonight is uh the form of a question uh
is scripture a straight line or a circle
and so our our passage is Ephesians
chapter 3 verses 1-6 and what I want you
to really tune in here into here is the
language of the mystery that Paul keeps
referencing throughout this this text.
So uh the apostle Paul writes he says
for this reason I Paul the prisoner of
Christ Jesus for the sake of you
Gentiles surely you've heard about the
administration of God's grace that was
given to me for you that is the mystery
made known to me by revelation as I've
already written briefly in reading this
then you will be able to understand my
insight into the mystery of Christ which
was not made known to people in other
generations as it has now been revealed
by the spirit to God's holy apostles and
prophets. This mystery is that through
the gospel of the gentile or through the
gospel of the gentiles are heirs
together with Israel, members together
of one body and sharers together in the
promise in Christ Jesus.
So something that uh theologian John
Bear points out is that as modern
Christians, we tend to kind of start our
understanding of
Christian theology and what I mean by
that I know that can sound kind of in
its own way kind of academic and like do
I have a Christian theology? Well, if
you have opinions about God and Jesus
and church and you know, well, then
you've started down the road of
developing your theology, right? So what
what bearer kind of points out is we
often
come to
kind of church and our theology
already with the framework of the Bible
kind of set and there as kind of a
given.
And now what do I mean by the Bible? So,
this gets into a message last week where
we talked about how it's it's a weird
thought to think that the Bible as like
a specific book and even the Methodist
church here has you know literal Bibles
like in underneath your I know most of
us like access the Bible now on our
phones and stuff but you know if you
look at the Bible it's weird to think
that is like a technology
like in the sense of a book right there
was a time when books were not we don't
think of books as technology but you
that one point 500 years ago it was like
wow So what I want you to kind of think
through is okay imagine if you just have
the scriptures as various scrolls just
writings kind of a little bit scattered
here and there. So in other words you
don't have kind of like an established
the book with these exact books in that
exact order. So that's what beer is
trying to get us to think through is
like oh isn't it interesting how for
example we all know like oh the book of
Genesis well that comes at the beginning
right so Genesis and Exodus Leviticus
and it's sort of this is the order ah
but that's the trick right before you
have a bible a book you don't have like
with the psalms psalms is in the middle
if you can't find the psalm you know go
here open you know I mean like that
order that structure so that's kind of
his point he's like oo think Think about
it. You've already come to the text with
like, okay, I know the story. I got the
whole lay of the land here. It starts
here, ends there, you know. Uh, that's a
good sound effect. I like that. Uh,
so he says, so his kind of point is when
we already have this kind of the story
of the Bible as a framework,
then we how do we view Christ? Well,
Christ has a role.
He has a place. in the story, a very
important place, but his place comes
somewhere in the middle.
Can you see where this is starting to
kind of influence how like how we think
of things and even how we we think of
Christ? So, like for example, if you
take like a class on like theology or
and specifically like biblical theology,
you might uh get a a timeline of
scripture that goes something like this.
We have this slide, although I couldn't
fit it all. it would be too small. But
just imagine that this uh timeline with
like creation,
fall, flood. There's a lot going on
here. So imagine that was one line,
right? That's the Bible. Creation, fall,
flood, Abraham, Moses, Isaiah, exile,
incarnation, and incarnation. That's uh
Christ coming from heaven to earth,
right? So incarnation, then the cross,
then resurrection, and then the
ascension, and then Pentecost. It's like
the falling of the spirit and then you
got the disciples and this time of the
apostles and then you got the season of
the church. This is where we are now and
then one day second coming new creation.
That'll be our next series. So this
framework this is kind of bears point is
we bring this framework
to like as like pre it's sort of like a
bakedin thing. We already have all this
locked in
and then we know Jesus place is right
there in the middle in the kind of
second half of the of the story.
So
we might say God we would say in our
understanding God is like God is up to
this God is up to this story this
narrative and Christ is a very very
important character in that drama.
And my point in this message, just so
you don't misunderstand, is not to be
like that's wrong, you know, or that's a
lie, that's not true, you know, not so
much. Like, no, no, I I get like and
even ancient, you know, the earliest
Christians had some kind of feeling for
that narrative, you know, I mean, that
kind of time. But can you see though
where that that framework though is very
much kind of dictated by the books of
the Bible that you have in that
particular order? I mean, that's kind of
why you think like, for example, if our
Bibles all had the gospels at the
beginning,
like the book started there. It's like
Jesus,
you know, and then you kind it would
kind of like, you know, I mean, it
starts to shift and change how you're
how you're viewing. So, let me I'll
unpack this kind of as we as we go. Um
so what's interesting is if you go back
though and read some of the works of say
like the apostle Paul or like very early
Christian theologians like Irenaeus or
origin
they what's interesting is they don't
yet have that framework like baked in.
Why? Well, because they have some of the
writings, right? But they but they don't
have the Bible, the physical thing right
there that's like, you know what I mean?
They don't have that yet. So, what what
kind of uh what does this do? Well, um
what instead what they had was this kind
of collection of writings,
but for them really Christ was not a
character who comes in at the middle of
the story.
Christ is like everything.
Christ is the beginning. Christ is the
middle. Christ is the ending. Christ So,
in other words, when they came to the
Bible, they're not like, "Oh, I'm in
Leviticus, so man, I can't wait to get
to this and sometime I'll get to Jesus,
you know." No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. That's the framework. That's you
kind of like, "Oh, so you say and Jesus,
his time comes about 800 pages later,
you know, like, no, no, no, no, no.
That's not how the earliest Christians
read the Bible. It was Christ all the
way through. If I had to kind of um sum
this up, uh would say rather than
thinking of scripture as a kind of
straight line, creation, Christ, church,
we might be better served thinking of
scripture actually as a circle
with Christ at the center.
So in other words, even thinking of
something like the incarnation of Jesus
is not so much what happens at a certain
point in the story. Um the incarnation,
the cross, the resurrection of Jesus is
actually all throughout the story. It is
the it's the revelation. It's the
mystery as Paul was using. That's why I
drew on that passage. It's the mystery
that Paul's talking about. Right? In
other words, as Paul went, this was his
like great obsession. He's going back
and he's reading other script Isaiah,
the Psalms, right? And not just Paul,
but all the early Christians, and
they're like,
the themes are all there. It's all
present, right? In other words, it's not
like, man, too bad the Old Testament
doesn't really talk about Jesus. Just
too bad, you know? But hey, at least we
have these New Testament writings we're
writing now. We have the Gospels, and
now we can make a fresh start. They're
like, no, no, that's not how they read
it. for them Christ was present all
throughout it. Um so if scripture is a
circle it might kind of look something
um like this. You can go ahead and put
up that that figure. U this is how John
Bear kind of frames it up. So in this
kind of picture the outer kind of large
circle there think of that as scripture.
Now kind of drawing on the message last
week again my point in naming that isn't
so much to try to like get really
particular about like these books of the
Bible this is exactly scripture and
those aren't. you know, because this is
where like Catholics, Eastern Orthodox,
Protestants all fight over like you who
include the Apocrypha, that's unholy,
you know, or whatever. It's weird. And
so I whatever, right? The early church
there's like hundreds of years where
they just didn't even feel the need to
like pin down like what's like the
official list, man, you know? So, okay,
but still there is, you know, scripture,
right? So, that's kind of the outer
circle, but then notice we have an inner
circle.
This would be the gospels.
uh Matthew, Mark, Luke, John. So that's
kind of the heart. Why? Because that's
the revelation of Christ. And then you
notice we have the four um lines. This
is the cross, right? And the cross and
you could really expand that to include
incarnation, resurrection, but
specifically the heart of the cross is
that's again all throughout scripture.
So in other words, when I read the
Bible, I'm looking for the unveiling,
for the revealing, for the mystery of
Christ.
And and I mean that not just in term in
terms of like some sort of symbolism,
although some of that, right, the early
church was they did a lot of allegorical
reading because of this, right? But even
beyond that, I even mean just for the
the themes,
you know, the the the
uh the sacrif the the themes of
sacrificial love, the the themes like
this was one of Paul's uh focuses was
the inclusion of the Gentiles, you know.
So, in other words, anywhere where like
the Jesus stuff was happening in the
Bible, it's just like, oh, there it is
right there. There it's it's jumping out
at us. Um so one way to kind of say this
is on its own
apart from Christ without that inner
circle
the outer circle is a kind of uh very
interesting record of the history the
wisdom literature uh and the various
writings of um the the uh ancient
peoples living in and around Canaan in
later Palestine.
uh it becomes the word of God when it is
read, interpreted and proclaimed in such
a way that Christ crucified and
resurrected is revealed. Right? In other
words, I could do a series on I don't
know, pick your book, you know, Genesis,
Exodus, whatever. And it could be I
could be teaching you the Bible and it
could be profoundly uncchristian,
uncristlike. I could fail to preach the
gospel. but also the reverse. We could
do a series on that book and it could be
deeply Christian, right? Even though it
never literally says like Jesus Christ,
right? So, so it's it's about how you
read it, how you interpret it. Um, I
would say it's really the same with the
so-called, you know, New Testament. The
New Testament, the Testament is not part
of that or that part of the story that
comes after the Old. The the New
Testament really in its kind of strict
sense is the revelation, the mystery of
Christ uh in the inclusion of the
Gentiles and really all people as God's
people. hiding in plain sight in all of
scripture. If I had to sum it up, we
could say Christ is the heart of all the
scriptures, right? Christ is the key
that unlocks the door of revelation.
And the Bible participates in that
mystery to the degree that it is read
and interpreted in light of the
goodness, beauty, and truth of Christ.
This is some of what I'm getting at is
for for the Bible to be the word of God
to to um reveal the love of God to
reveal Christ to us it is all about how
it is read how it is interpreted
all about that
and if we go wrong there like we go very
wrong now why does this need to be named
you know is my point to kind of
denigrate the Bible tear it down say oh
it's worthless and you know all I care
about is Jesus or all we need is the
gospels and that's it. Just throw
everything else, you know, else out. No,
I'm not saying that. Um, I read the
Bible, pray with the Bible. This morning
I was, you know, I have little Bible.
I've been very into Bible memory
recently. I have this little app and I'm
like trying to memorize parts of the
Bible. It's like, you know, like a kid
in Sunday school again. It's great. And
uh so I this is this is important. Um I
I do think the Bible is is deeply
essential to Christian faith in
practice. It's just that uh some
Christians have theologically started
with the Bible and then tried to work
their way back to Christ
but never made it
or by the time they do make it all of
their doctrines all their Christian
thinking has been so influenced
by the Bible
that Christ is not able to make their
theology very Christlike.
So what do I mean by this? Well, for
example, um you could build up a whole
very elaborate doctrine of God
from the Bible.
And that God could be like a total
monster. Like I mean, if you've really
read the Bible front to back, you I
mean, just just cherry pick your
passages, you know what I mean? Like
real problematic like real, you know,
we're talking genocidal stuff, you know
what I mean? Like you could do that. Uh
it's a it's a problem. But instead, if I
would say like, no, no, no. We must
build our doctrine of God rooted in who?
In Christ, in Jesus, right? Uh if you've
seen me, you've seen the father.
that. So, we start we start there.
I just uh I've seen even so many people
leave the faith because they don't
understand this. They're like, I've read
the Bible and it's just problematic. You
know what I mean? And then it's just
like ah oh, you know, you don't you
don't don't get it. it it's we got to
start with um Christ and and then we go
back to the broader scriptures and then
we deepen and we enrich and we you know
we kind of can go from there and of
course the same could go for any other
aspect of theology. Um, this is why I
generally don't like um, and I mean this
in the strict theological sense. I don't
like what's known as biblical theology,
which sounds like you're pastor, you not
like biblical theology. What the heck?
You know, but I by that I mean there's
like a a certain strand of Protestant
theology, a certain way of doing
theology. That is everything I've been
pushing back on this sermon. It is
precisely the frame. We start with the
Bible. we start and then we'll you know
kind of fit Jesus into this and I just
find it incredibly problematic right um
so and there's even books you know you
can find books like a biblical theology
of fill in the blank you know a biblical
theology of God uh a biblical theology
of marriage a biblical theology of
womanhood a biblical theology of manhood
a biblical theology of war, a biblical
theology, you know, I mean, just
whatever. Just put fill it in. Um,
and I think like, oh no. I mean, anytime
I see a biblical theology of like, oh,
oh no, this is going this is going to go
sideways. Um, now why? What do you mean
why? What we want is a Christian
theology of fill in the blank, right?
And by Christian, um, I don't mean a
church history theology. I mean, a
Christ centered, Christ saturated
theology of
whatever, you know what I mean? Uh, God,
uh, war, politics, I mean, just on and
on and on. It's it's got to be there,
though, right? It's got that's got to be
the the heart, the the center of the
thing, right? It's got to So, we've got
to start with Christ, his life, his
death, his resurrection as revealed in
the gospels. And only then do we begin
to look out to the rest of scripture to
see where the mystery is revealed. In
other words, we start with that in the
circle paradigm. We start with that
center circle. I mean, this is where
like for a new Christian, I would say
spend your first three years reading the
Gospels. Just read the Gospels. Just
take it. And and again, not as a way of
in there and never read anything else.
It was problematic. That's not what I'm
saying. I'm saying saturate yourself in
the gospels. Really start to get to the
heart of who Jesus is. Then you go out
from there. Then you you can um build
and understand more, right? Then we can
see how the mystery is uh is revealed.
Okay. So what are some of the kind of
implications of of all of this? And I
hope it hasn't been too I don't know
high fallutin or high theological or I
hope I'm not not losing you but may
maybe this will help to kind of anchor
it a little bit. So what does this like
mean for your life you know and like how
we actually read the Bible? Number one
shift your lens.
Shift your lens. So as you read the
Bible and particularly the Old Testament
don't just focus on like what happens
next in the story. Um, ask yourself, how
does the cross of Jesus Christ um, open
up this text for me?
How does the incarnation, the the
resurrection of Jesus, how does it
enliven, open up? How is it like calling
to me in this text? And by the way, if
it's not, well, just keep moving. You
know, I mean, if it's kind of like, I'm
not sure about that. I don't Hey, yikes.
You know, okay, that's fine, right?
Don't get hung up like I can't be a
Christian anymore. Just it's fine. just
keep moving. And maybe there'll be a way
of reading that text, interpret it later
that the spirit reveals to you. You
realize like, oh, actually, I thought
that was like 100% problematic. Nothing
good can come from that ever, ever,
ever. And then I realize later like, oh,
actually there's something to that or
yeah, no, I can see where it, you know
what I mean? Um, so this is where I'm
not a fan of Marcian who wanted to like
throw out certain parts of the Bible or
like the God of the Old Testament is the
devil and get rid of it. And that was he
was an early Christian who saw this and
that's what he wanted to do. He was like
get rid of the Old Testament. You know,
I'm not saying that. Um, but we do need
to read it with the the revelation of
the God who is love in mind. The one
who's bringing all people together as
Paul wrote in verse six, "This mystery
is that through the gospel, the Gentiles
are heirs together with Israel, members
together of one body, sharers together
in the promise in Jesus Christ." What
would it be like to read the Old
Testament with that revelation, that
mystery in mind? What are the stories of
unlikely people or groups being
reconciled and healed and made whole all
throughout scripture? You know, that's
like a different angle. So, shift your
shift your lens. Second, reframe the
story. I was kind of alluding to this
earlier, but how you begin your theology
and your God thoughts, how you begin,
where you start, like really really
matters. If you begin with once there
was a great fall, the first human beings
were the worst and God was so angry at
them because all humans are evil
wretches through and through.
Well, that's going to play out in your
theology, my friend. Right? And you say,
in other words, you're getting your
doctrine of humanity, of what the human
is from certain chapters of like Genesis
and others. You're starting there. I'm
going to start here and it makes sense.
It's the first book of the Bible, you
know. Uh if instead you read the book of
images of book of Genesis with an image
of God informed by Christ there, you
might notice a bit more of the fact that
all that was created was good, good and
even very good. In other words, we began
in original blessing and only then came
into a season of ignorance and struggle.
So again, don't think Jesus comes in at
the middle or the end of the story like
no no let Christ reframe the beginning,
the middle, the end, everything in
between. every book, every chapter,
every verse. Third, read for
illumination.
You know, when we read the Bible, it's
not so much information we're after, but
really an an illumination by the Holy
Spirit, right? We yearn for the spirit
to to kind of reveal, to show us Christ,
the heart of scripture. Why? In order
that we ourselves might be transformed.
I mean, in the end, if we're not reading
the Bible for a deep yearning for
transformation,
uh, and even transfiguration,
longing that that what, um, that what
God has done in Christ, some taste of
that would be done in me, you know, like
that's like that's what it's about. You
if we're not doing that, it's just like,
I don't know, interesting historical
studies and you know, and the Bible is
super interesting and academics too just
study it. They don't even believe
anything about, you know, they're just
like this fascinating. is it's
fascinating but that's not how we read
it in the church right we're reading for
like illumination
uh deep deep profound change there's a
quote from John Bear he says unveiled by
the cross the scriptures that's the old
testament he has in mind have a specific
exugesus that means interpretation that
enables them to be read not as a myth
but in terms of types and parables an
exesus that moreover illuminates the
reader so they themselves are the ones
glorified the thing that kind of jumps
out at me there is bears language of
myth versus parable and how when
interpreted as a parable the scriptures
I would say especially the old testament
become spiritually illuminating for us.
Um I think to give this kind of I know
that's academic so let me kind of break
this down like I think many modern
Christians for example can be very
thrown off by certain old testament
stories. take the story of Noah's ark.
He's a great one, right? And it's an
easy one to teach the kids in case we
just kind of excuse certain problematic
sides. You know, we're kind of like, oh
yeah. Um, but as adults, you kind of
grow up and then you start thinking
about that story and you're just kind of
like, I don't, you know, it and so you
get kind of two groups of camp, like two
camps, uh, in the Christian community.
You know, one is like, well, no, that's
just how it happened. And it's very
important that we say that's just how it
happened. and uh you know we're not
going to like go back on scripture or
something you know and the other group
is like no it didn't it's just
unscientific and should be ignored and
it's you know problematic and what I'm
saying is like well where however it
happened or or not I think is largely
irrelevant. Um, the question for the
church is how is it a parable of Christ?
That's the question. Which is funny
because as modern Christians, that's
like never the question we're asking.
You know what I mean? It's just I I
can't think I've ever gone to a church
where they're like Noah as a parable of
the modern church, you know, or
something like and I guess in that
Christ is like Noah and we're the
animals or something, you know? But this
is how honestly early Christians read
it. Like that's how they because again
they were look they read the scriptures
looking for Christ. So like this is how
they read it and it's just so far from
you know how how we um ever would. So
can you kind of see too where like for
early Christians they were less tied up
in the details of that story. They
weren't trying to build their whole
doctrine of God around that story. Which
if you do that, you get God as this
honestly rather silly character who's
like, man, sure do regret making all
these human beings. I guess I'm going to
have to murder them all now. You know,
like he's surprised. You know what I
mean? Kind of like I can't I can't
believe it. Look at him. They're just
acting a fool. You know, like
so that's read at the literal level and
it is it's kind of silly read as a type
in a parable.
It becomes interesting. It becomes
spiritually illuminating again.
I'll close with this quote from the
wonderful Christian theologian Rowan
Williams. He says, ' One of the great
tragedies and errors of the way people
have understood the Bible has been the
assumption that what people did in the
Old Testament must have been right
because it's in the Bible. It has
justified violence, enslavement, abuse,
and suppression of women, murderous
prejudice against gay people. It has
justified all manner of things we now
cannot but as Christians regard as evil.
But they are not there in the Bible
because God is telling us that's good.
They are there because God is telling us
you need to know that is how some people
responded.
You need to know that when I speak to
human beings things can go very wrong as
well as very wonderfully.
God tells us you need to know that when
I speak it isn't always simple to hear
because of what human beings are like.
We need, in other words, to guard
against the temptation to take just a
bit of the whole story and treat it as
somehow a model for our own behavior.
Christians have often been down that
road, and it has not been a pretty
sight. We need rather to approach the
Bible as if it were a parable of Jesus.
That's it.
That's it. That's like my whole sermon
in one sentence. He just Ran Williams is
smarter than I, so he just summed it up.
The whole thing is a gift, a challenge,
an invitation into a new world. Seeing
yourself aresh and more truthfully.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held a loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said, "Take
it. This is my body. It's broken for
you. And he held the cup of wine. He
said, "Take it. Drink. This is my blood.
It's shed for you. Whenever you eat this
bread, whenever you drink this cup,
remember me." And so, as we come forward
to the table of the Lord, we long to
commune, to connect with the crucified
and resurrected one. The way we'll um
participate in communion tonight is
we'll um just kind of go row by row and
just forming one line right here in uh
in the middle. When one row finishes,
the next one can go ahead and, you know,
get up and jump in the line. Uh we
practice what's called an open table.
Meaning, if you're here tonight and
you'd like to participate, uh you're
welcome to do that regardless of your,
you know, exact theology or denomination
or whatever you something in you wants
to connect with the risen Christ, then
you're you're free to to do that. Um at
the same time, there's no pressure. If
you'd rather not, that's that's okay,
too. You should know the red is wine,
the white is grape juice. And uh
finally, you can just partake whenever
and however you'd like. Some folks like
to take it right away. Others like to
come and kneel here at the front. Some
return to their seats, but no one will
lead you through the exact moment of
partaking. So, this is the table,
not of the church, but of the Lord, and
it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more.
So come you who have much faith and you
who have little. You who have been here
often and you who have not been here
long. You who have tried to follow and
you who have failed. Come. Come because
it's the Lord Jesus himself who invites
you. And it's his will that those who
want to meet him should meet him here.
Come to the table.
[Music]
Would
you guys, if you'd like to, if you're
able, stand back with us. Um, we're
going to finish out with the song we
opened with, Never See the End. Let's
just sing that together again,
remembering the goodness of God and his
promises.
Where can we run?
Where can we hide?
You will not find
us.
The deepest of depths,
the highest of heights,
your loving chase
us.
No matter where we've been,
no matter where we've done,
we can't escape
your love.
[Music]
And we will never see the end. We will
never see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your Let's sing that one more time.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
[Music]
And in our darkest hour and on our
hardest day,
we do not have to be afraid.
For you will never leave.
You will not forsake.
the promises you have made.
And in our darkest hour,
and on our hardest days,
we do not have to be afraid.
You will never leave.
You will not forsake
the promises you have made.
We can say
we will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your good
words. We will never see the end. We
will never see the end
of your goodness.
[Music]
Well, thank you so much for joining us
this evening. If you're new and you
would like uh to fill out a visitor's
card, you can do that online or you can
pick one up at the table um right at by
the door. Fill out that visitors card
for us. Um if you're interested in
getting involved more and you call the
table home, but you don't currently
serve on a ministry team, then we would
love for you to try out one. We have the
tech team team in the back. We have the
children's uh ministry and we have the
host team that Scott is involved with.
And um currently those are the ones that
are most in need, but there are other
ministries that you can join. Uh fill
out a card over there on that table or
you can scan that QR code.
Generosity is a key aspect of a life of
adoration and worship. If the table is
your current church home, then we invite
you to scan the QR code to give
financially or you may visit the
tabletx.org.
And now I'd like to send you out with
this blessing
your week. You can hold out your hands
to uh receive or you can just open your
hearts to these words.
You are a child of God.
Yes, you are a child of God. This is
true on your best day and it is true on
your worst day.
So, as you go out into your week ahead,
and it's yet to be determined, highs and
lows and everything in between, go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved, that you are worthy,
that you are accepted just as you are,
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts
of grace and unconditional love to
everyone that you come in contact with.
Be blessed and we'll see you next
Sunday.
[Music]
We do not have to be afraid.